Now, companies that are still doing the
traditional assessment today, which
essentially means that you are um
investing a certain amount of money um
for for doing a static assessment that
will give you a view of what issues you
have, what vulnerabilities, what
weaknesses, and then we'll give you um
maybe a plan for remedi doing
remediation for the set. that will keep
you busy for a certain amount of time
while um life is still moving on. So
things are still evolving and threats
are still no coming in and you might
need to adjust. Uh therefore the
traditional way of doing things
essentially will allow you to have um
yeah just a static view of things and
then start planning for them and you
will have to take a program and continue
it etc. that will burn money immediately
and then will leave you very little time
for flexibility. With the CACR
methodology, essentially you don't need
to go through a full-blown assessment.
You will just decide, I want to cover
the scope. I have the system. I want to
verify. You can jump in right away.
Start going through your your sprint
cycles of assessment and remediation.
[Music]
Mario Proio, welcome to the human zero
day. Really, really excited to have you
here with me uh talking about AI, cyber
security, human security, everything
related. Thank you so much for being
here. Thank you and very happy to join.
Yeah, really intrigued by the topic by
the way. Yeah, I mean we're we're we're
talking about I think probably the most
uh some of the most exciting topics
around um around security yourself
today. you're the founder of Proiso and
and the the methodology which you've
shared with me which I'm really excited
to dive into today really talks about
how do you continuously assess risk and
how do you remediate risk and part of
what is I think really exciting in
today's world is that the risk of humans
and human security is changing
constantly and so I'm really looking
forward to hearing your insights as a
CISO and as an entrepreneur on on
addressing those risks especially as we
don't know where they're heading but I'm
getting ahead of myself. Mario, you're
you have quite an extensive background
as as a CISO um and and now with
Proceeds. So, tell me a little bit about
your journey all the way from from when
you started because you've been at this
really from the emergence of the
internet even a little bit before that.
Yeah, correct. Correct. So, um I started
actually as a developer. So I was really
um interested in uh you know building
things, developing applications and uh
that that was really exciting times and
I must say I still look back at that
because it allows me to see the insights
of applications you know how
applications work and you consider a lot
of security issues. Many of security
problems come exactly from bad coding
right development of applications. So
it's yeah it's a good good to have that
kind of insight. Um beyond that yeah it
was the times of uh of the internet. So
um exciting times people were starting
to connect and uh and there were
opportunities you know to um yeah to to
see this evolution
of um um services which were being uh
available on on connectivity on services
on on telos and I was supporting uh the
startup. So we started up with Italian
line the new um internet provider in
Italy the first one actually and there I
was mostly on the uh networking side and
therefore seeing things uh from that
perspective which is also very
interesting and uh uh helps also to to
have an understanding of of how certain
things work right connectivity at that
time there were no firewalls so we we
had to be uh creative in trying to
protect our services uh directly on
routters so creating ACL's directly on
on the routters themselves. Then beyond
that, of course, going more focused into
into security and um essentially, you
know, building up uh those capabilities
which uh then evolved like intrusion
prevention systems that help to protect
better the the environment of of
applications and um eventually I mean my
career was mostly as a CESO and not more
more or less 20 years that I've been in
in this role in this area. I've been a
CESO in Telos uh in Italy and also
global enterprises and um essentially
the experience that I managed to squeeze
out of uh of that kind of role you know
being a CISO in big corporations gives
you uh visibility of technical issues uh
in very important processes and then the
human element you know being able to
also integrate that and and the security
measures need to encompass a bit of
everything. So we always say yeah
process you know technology and people
and um and that is totally true also in
cyber security of course. So so Mario a
lot for us to unpack. I I want to
quickly just grasp that this transition
from developer to security. What do you
remember? What was it for you that made
you make that leap from being a
developer to being a security
professional? What was it?
Well, um security essentially there was
an opportunity for me to you know to to
build up a team because there was a
necessity. Um but uh the the the
progress from uh application development
uh to networking and to security I think
uh gave me yeah the opportunity of
seeing the different dimension different
uh perspectives uh which are not so
common or not so obvious if seen know
within their individual silo. Um so
essentially that sort of gives a a
panoramic 360deree view of uh of how
things operate and integrate with each
other and the complexities of each.
Yeah. So you've been at the CISO
capacity for the last I guess two
decades. you've and and and you know as
a young security practitioner myself you
know more so on the offensive side I've
I've I've been fascinated looking at
this this journey from you know the
firewalls and 95 to
you know malware detection with semantic
and then cloud security and identity
security and it feels like every few
years there's this whole new category of
security uh risk management that opens
up and we're adding a few more acronyms
and Gartner adds a new magic quadrant
and and I mean it keeps on growing and
growing. Can you share with me a little
bit about your own experience? How has
it been like for you operating in a
landscape where you have certain risks
that you're managing and then every now
and then you have to be open to
accepting a new modality that you now
have to tackle and it's almost if and
and how do you also do that in
accordance with your organization
because you effectively have to go back
to your org and try to get them to
understand this risk and why perhaps you
need more budget etc. walk me through
your experience with evol with the
evolutions of cyber security.
Yeah, indeed. So that's uh one of the
biggest challenges because uh cyber
security itself is extremely dynamic and
there are so many variables you know
which can change. So uh you mentioned
threats uh there new challenging
sophisticated um the new know entry
points vectors of access and um there
are um risks which appear continuously
there are vulnerabilities which are
published know every month and then
there is the the organization itself
that is evolving it's changing it's
adapting to new businesses it's uh
deploying new applications migrating to
the cloud doing you know um digital
transformations etc. So all of these
need to be um viewed in their um in
their holistic know um view. So
considering all of these aspects and
being able to um yeah to to drive and
and to prioritize based on uh you know
the elements that are uh fundamental for
that period of time or that uh that
requirement. What I like to highlight
all the time is that um it's
foundational to be able to have
visibility of of uh what the
organization has. So starting from its
assets or its infrastructure, if it's
using cloud, if it's using on-prem and
and clearly understanding, you know, um
um where the systems are, what they're
doing, what data is processed, etc.
That's why I say for me it's
foundational to have um a riskmanagement
program uh which essentially allows you
to identify and here we can actually um
um connect with the NIST framework which
says it really nicely the the
representation of of the NIST clearly
identifies how cyber security needs to
uh be uh properly integrated with
different phases different capabilities
starting from the identify phase where
you will actually know your assets,
understand what they do, um um classify
them, understand what data they're
processing, who is allowed to access
them, what is their exposure, etc. And
then you will be able to protect based
on the knowledge that you have. You will
decide what security measures you would
want to implement. And then you when
those will fail, you have to have
capabilities to detect that uh something
have managed to bypass those protective
measures. Then you have to respond when
an incident happens and then recover.
And overlining this or underlining this
is the governance phase which allows you
to put everything together and ensure
that you are um and managing the entire
ecosystem with harmony and uh with
proper you know holistic vision. Mhm. So
if we look at the evolution of cyber
security and we connect it to this to
the to the cycle that you just
mentioned. I'm I'm really curious about
this first pillar which is the risk
assessment. Right. and you're trying to
to evaluate what is the risk that I'm
prone to because the next question is
going to be well how do I how do I
proactively defend and protect against
this risk. Uh how how what are the tools
that you h that CISOs have today that
you've had and others have to evaluate
and quantify risk based on their own
organization? H how do what does that
pro thought process look like? Yeah
indeed that's uh there are many
methodologies for quantifying risk. You
can quantify risk in a um yeah
qualitative way meaning you will
understand more or less the impacts of
uh certain elements you know the
likelihood the impact that that a threat
can damage your company or you can even
go into figures and have you know uh
numbers connected to that that is quite
complex to achieve. You can do it based
on value of asset or you can also uh do
that based on value of the outcome of a
service. And so what would happen if
that service would be disrupted for a
certain amount of time, you know, then
what what would I as a as an enterprise
um where would I lose money and how much
would I lose? Um but beyond going into
that, I mean it's really important that
an organization has some sort of um risk
methodology that they can implement
being it quantitative or qualitative.
It's it's really important that there is
one. You can also go to the fair
institute and they have a very
interesting quantitative methodology. Um
we've built our uh methodology which we
called CACR so continuous assessment
continuous remediation. So it's
mimicking the CI/CD in DevOps uh with
the concept of being able to um repeat
um short and frequent cycles. So we call
them sprint assessment sprints which uh
allows u any organization of any size to
immediately start working in um a risk
approached way. So you will be able to
um identify those systems that are more
important for your business, those that
are important because they're processing
personal data and then you will be able
to go through an an infinite loop and
that's how we represent it in which one
of the tools that we make use of is
threat modeling. And threat modeling we
repeated twice in the in the assessment
phase and in the remediation phase where
we uh break down uh the services that we
are analyzing um into uh boundaries and
and ingress points, aggress uh where
data can flow in where users can access.
What type of users are we talking about?
Are these uh consumers are these
administrators? Uh what data do they do
they have access to? And then we try
identify threats that could you know be
um could be attacking could be uh
hurting this the service and we come
with remediation ideas and based on then
on these results we will evaluate also
on the um effectiveness of certain
actions and then prioritized based on uh
the effectiveness of these. So we will
be able to and and on on the impacts on
risk reduction of of these uh counter
measures that we would implement. By the
way, Mario, I love the CACR um
terminology and the analogy to CICD,
which is a world that I'm very much fond
of. But walk how is this different than
what we've had before? So if you were to
look at the way that a CISO or an
organization would model its assessment
and then threat and then and then
remediation, how did that look like 5
years ago versus the world that you're
envisioning today? What's the
difference? Well, not even going back 5
years ago actually. There are many no
companies that are still doing the
traditional assessment today which
essentially means that you are um
investing a certain amount of money um
for for doing a static assessment that
will give you a view of what issues you
have, what vulnerabilities, what
weaknesses and then we'll give you um
maybe a plan for remedi doing
remediation for the set that will keep
you busy for a certain amount of time
while um life is still moving on. So
things are still evolving and threats
are still know coming in and you might
need to adjust. Uh therefore the
traditional way of doing things
essentially will allow you to have um
yeah just a static view of things and
then start planning for them and you
will have to take a program and continue
it etc. That will burn money immediately
and then will leave you very little time
for flexibility. With the CACR
methodology, essentially you don't need
to go through a full-blown assessment.
You will just decide, I want to cover
the scope. I have the system. I want to
verify. You can jump in right away,
start going through your your sprint
cycles of assessment and remediation.
Assessment on remediation, which can be
parallelized. So, they can work very
quickly and can be very effective and in
time. So, they're always very current.
And then it leaves you the flexibility
to
um either extend the scope so make it
broader and and add new systems or
adjust on priority and and or adjust on
the framework that you have uh
implemented. For example, you say now we
have N 2 which is uh um as we we need to
yeah some companies need to um adhere to
and um you don't need to scramble. you
will just uh verify what additional
controls you need to add into your
existing framework, harmonize them and
then you just keep going with your
cycle. No hassle and uh no problems. Um
so essentially that becomes very very uh
flexible um easy to adjust and adapt
based on know what is going on if
there's new threats that you need to
prioritize or if your business needs uh
more attention elsewhere.
And so it sounds like you're really
taking this from a periodic I don't know
whether it's quarterly or bianually
maybe you can share more approach that
CISOs would do and and I'm hearing a lot
about you know the way that CISOs
present to the board you know here are
the top threats here's what I'm going to
do next year and it sounds like a very
static you know point in time approach
you're really talking about an agile
methodology bringing it to the risk uh
risk and remediation
context, right? So, how how big of a
shift are you talking about here? Is it
instead of once a month, we do it once
every two weeks or is it as big as once
a quarter, we do it once every two
weeks? Yeah, correct. So, normally, as
you were mentioning, um, companies would
have a campaign which is a yearly
campaign and you would provide results.
Then, maybe the more mature would say we
have quarterly reporting and so you
would report to the board on a quarterly
basis. we can easily um get to the point
in which we can report uh on a monthly
basis but also with tools this can be
done actually real time. So we can
integrate uh the results uh that we have
based on you know the status in which we
are uh where the progress of remediation
actions and we can in any point of time
just at a click of a button provide a
report where we are where we stand and
that gives uh a few benefits. one is to
the CESO himself. He knows where he
stands, what he needs to still do, what
he and what he's achieved and he could
demonstrate achievements to the board
and say, "Hey, this is uh what I had
planned to do. I'm covering these risks.
This is how I spent my budget and this
is what I still need to do for the next
cycle, the next sprint. Therefore, this
is no what I need for funding and I will
cover these other risks." And that
becomes then um an easy program to
follow up on and everyone is fully
aligned. there's a lot of visibility.
You have a good understanding. You you
have a good plan and you can adjust
flexibly. It doesn't have to be a static
one-year-old plan. And then you can
review it at the end of the year. And
are there elements already in cyber
security that have begun to shift to
this I guess CACR mindset? Because I
would imagine that there's elements in
in the attack surface where CISOs are
understanding that they need more
continuous realtime feedback on their on
their posture management versus other
areas which are more static. H is there
a already a shift there or is this
something that's that's still very much
in the static world? No, indeed. So if
we go then into operational um elements
uh then we will uh and there's always
been this need for visibility of what's
going on and it's an essential
capability and indeed the NIST framework
um identifies this in two out of five
phases right so you will have detect and
respond which are two capabilities which
are actually real time so the more data
you're capable more telemetry you're
capable of pulling in from systems from
endpoints from uh routters, firewalls,
etc. uh cloud environments. Uh the the
more the granularity you will have in
your dashboards of what actually is
going on and uh you will be able to
capture those weak signals. And um of
course you will this it's very important
to then create uh content and use cases
which are relevant to your context and
are relevant to your business dynamics.
Right? So if you have people that travel
very frequently, you will have a
conditional access that will take in
account that that possibility. You don't
want to overanoy
your uh end users, your uh your
employees, you know, um challenging them
with 2FA all the time. But um you know
the better you have an understanding of
of your company and how it works and you
more integrated into the business um the
better you will be able to tune your
machine that receives this information
that will generate the alerting based on
that and the logics that you want to
give to it. So indeed sock capabilities
are fundamental and nowadays we have
more and more information which uh yeah
we need to be assisted by AI and uh and
and being able to correlate very quickly
and understand you know if uh there are
any weak signals and be able to jump on
them and act upon them. So you've been
now um I know working with with
different CESOs on this and you yourself
are you know with more than two decades
of experience. What is the reception
that you're getting from the audience on
on adopting this methodology methodology
adopting this mindset taking a more
iterative agile approach to risk
assessment and remediation? What has
been the feedback you're getting?
Indeed, it there's a lot of interest and
um essentially it's um consolidating
into a streamlined methodology with um
very clear steps that that need to be
followed. Uh the diagram is available.
Anybody could actually follow it. um
it's uh I would say common sense but um
the the way we implement it and then we
help companies to execute that then
that's that becomes a bit of a gamecher
because um indeed um it simplifies the
way um cycles of risk management are are
done and uh it definitely gets more
engagement and involvement. um CISOs
like it because they are then capable of
demonstrating to the board um what their
security posture is like at that current
moment in time with that current um
maturity level that they have. So it
might be that you know companies already
have a lot of visibility and can
demonstrate u a lot of information
others are starting new and then they
have really nothing to show. So that
that it's an opportunity with this
methodology to start small and show
immediately right. So you can even start
with just a couple of systems and uh go
through the process and already have
visibility and identify some risks.
Threat modeling will will illuminate uh
areas of risk immunity that you can show
to the board and you can explain in
understandable risk terms and um and
therefore um yeah get into this uh
discussion uh which which can continue
with uh with board members uh C levels
and then integrate also with the rest of
of the team the IT team ensuring that
everyone is fully on board and you're
sharing you know what the objectives are
what your targets what are the systems
you will be working on and because
security by the way is not just an
isolated function it needs to be fully
integrated with IT with HR you know
we're talking about humans as well and
therefore um being properly integrated
within the entire organization
I love it so so let's let's take a look
for a second at this infinite cycle
you're talking about which I think makes
sense to me would be relevant for any
attack surface on the organization and I
think we tal talked about that in one of
our other conversations about this idea
of how do you integrate technology to be
able to run to assist and run this this
process across different integrations,
right? And but but but and I want to d
use that as a as a segue to dive into
this context of humans and and and
attack the texts and the risks
associated with the emergence of social
engineering and fishing and and f even
before that give me your take on social
engineering and fishing in the context
of the enterprise because this has been
a a growing space since the first days I
think of the internet um with
evolutionary technology ology both in
detection and response as well as
awareness and training. What is your
take on on the social engineering and
fishing space?
Yeah, indeed. So, um
fishing is uh is is being uh a big
threat for many many years and it's
still continuing today. It's it's
probably the the biggest uh know attack
vector that that we know of. And um
there are two lines of thought here. So
uh some say that doing security
awareness uh doesn't really help because
the the human is weak and he will always
fall for that fishing attack right and
so they say no you need to invest in
technology and um others instead say no
but you need to combine because it's not
just about uh technology there are also
some social engineering attacks which
happen through uh other channels for
example just a phone call where you have
a fake IT guy who's calling ing you know
an employee saying hey I notice some
strange traffic coming out of your
laptop and you quickly go to this
website and click here and there yeah of
course you can block that website but if
the attacker is using a G drive for
example then you you won't be able to
block that website and uh no you you can
go into levels of sophistication so I
still believe that uh security awareness
is really important but what's important
is how you implement that security
awareness so if you implement it as um a
boring uh training corporate training
session then you won't get much uh
attention and much traction but if you
implement it and we've managed to do
that actually very successfully in in in
one of the uh companies I was working
for as a CISO we make it a a personal
educational opportunity right in which
we explain to uh employees how certain
threats could impact them personally
right so you have a Gmail account, why
don't you enable two-factor
authentication? Oh, it's it's it's your
personal email. Okay, nobody cares about
your email, but then maybe you have a
Bitcoin wallet and you're connecting
with that, right? To receive
notifications from that wallet and maybe
you didn't activate two-actor
authentication to your Bitcoin wallet
either. Now, then you start getting a
bit more attention. people are are
interested and if your awareness uh
campaign um blends you know both the
corporate requirements and the personal
interest of of the people then it will
be extremely successful. you will deploy
what we call a culture of security,
right? In which people are actually not
just interested, they are excited about
security. They will attend town halls,
you know, um October awareness month. Um
people were coming saying, "Hey, what
we're going to have uh this month, we
were bringing sessions of of hackers
doing, you know, demonstration, live
demonstrations of attacks or via Wi-Fi,
etc." And people just get more and more
excited and interested and they will be
um involved and and be able to also to
engage with the security team and not
just see the security team as a distant
team, one that will be checking on them
and then if they click on the link they
will be hammered because you know they
did the wrong thing but actually be able
to reach out, report and u ask questions
and um yeah look at the security team as
a team that can give tips and
suggestions.
Absolutely. And so if we're looking now
at the idea of a threat modeling and
risk assessment for social engineering,
we we realize it's a big threat, but how
are how are CISOs or organizations today
assessing the organization's resilience
to this to even identify where the
biggest pain points are and where they
should be investing resources to protect
their humans?
Well, well, what Caesars do normally uh
are uh campaigns. So, definitely there
are training campaigns maybe followed by
fishing campaigns. Uh so, trials
verifying and trying new also threats.
So, for example, QR code fishing now is
uh is quite new and subtle and um they
will try maybe doing also social
engineering attacks. Uh we did a few of
those as well in which people would just
try and enter the building uh without a
badge uh by just talking and uh reaching
out and saying hi to colleagues that
they didn't know about but nobody would
say hey who are you I don't know you and
then uh piggybacking through you know
into the office and then walking around
uh looking at what's on the desk taking
pictures of you know open laptops or USB
drives swapping USB drives and whatever
and then um doing a nice session after
all of that showing this is what we
found no and then and then uh
documenting everything with a video and
closing out you know showing what the
actual impacts could be. So giving some
results okay this no uh simulating what
could happen if the attacker had
actually done a certain action. So these
could be uh effective ways of working of
um of tackling these kind of risks and
uh I see CISOs actually implementing
some of them. Yeah. And so do you think
in your assessment today do you think
CISOs have a good understanding today of
the human zero day in their
organization? So where the humans are
susceptible, how they're susceptible and
and where the next the next attack may
come through. Do you feel like they have
good tools to be able to make those
assessments?
Well, the next zero day human attack
maybe not. So, I think traditional uh
attacks maybe yes. And again this really
depends on the maturity of of the
organization and of the CISO because
also really social engineering attacks
um are um are not so common but um they
they happen and they happen even on a
personal level right so everyone has
probably received a fake SMS from FedEx
you know saying hey click here because
we we're dropping your parcel or
received a phone call and um so these
are um not so new but uh not many CISOs
are actually doing anything about these
uh except maybe for training. So, um
yeah, going through um uh videos or
short quizzes to try and uh you know,
see if people have an understanding of
of this kind of attack because it sounds
to me like, you know, security
threats are evolving across the board
and this is exactly why you've founded
ProISO, right? This is why you're you're
saying security is changing so fast. The
rate of change of security changes is
changing. So the derivative is actually
positive which means that we need to be
faster and better at doing these
evaluations with the area that you know
this that we're focusing on especially
also here in this show it's this
question of the attacks on humans are
probably I think changing as at least as
fast as any other security
attack surface if not even more because
of AI generated content deep fakes the
fragmentation of attack vectors on the
humans. And so it sounds to me like the
way that the the model and the
methodology that you're bringing to the
security world in general is even more
dire and critical for human security.
Totally. And I mean that that's the
reason why we came up with this idea.
Now first of all uh because cyber
security is so complex uh we need to
find ways of making it easier. And how
do you make things easier? Typically uh
from an engineering perspective, you
break down a bigger problem into smaller
problems, right? Make them more frequent
and easier to handle. And that is the
concept of the CACR. So we we break down
the entire process into smaller ones. We
have uh nice functions which are which
are flexible which can accommodate uh
new systems, new threats and have uh
know understanding of uh the new
environment that we need to protect
against and uh and being able to yeah um
see and shift very quickly as uh as
needed to uh know to to to address new
threats and uh being extremely reactive.
Yeah, absolutely. Mario, what has been
the most fun aspect for you over the
last two decades as a CISO?
Oh, wow. Uh, there's so many nice
moments. We've had um yeah, we've had
compromises that those are normally
things that a CISO would not be proud
of. Uh but I think and um it's it's
important to be able to uh handle uh
compromises and be able to quickly react
to them, understand them and m minimize
know the impact of that. That's there's
a concept that was um highlighted I
think a couple of years ago uh called
resilience. No, and that is extremely
important to keep in mind. Uh resilient
means that um you can be compromised and
probably every company has or will be
compromised and it becomes really
important um to be able to res
understand um as quick as possible
possibly with um weak signals and then
quickly react and try and block the
attack as early as possible on the kill
chain. Right? The kill chain are
multiple steps that need to be followed.
Uh the quicker response the better of
course. So we've had a couple of of
really harsh incidents and um in uh one
specific it was in the times in which um
well not all traffic was encrypted. So
it it was uh enjoyable because we had
just deployed a system that would
monitor traffic on the network. And
thanks to that we managed to reconstruct
every single little piece of uh what the
attacker had done. How he deployed the
uh the shell and then how he did the
activated the back door and and then
introduced additional code etc. But also
recently in telco telco there's a lot of
visibility because that's where all the
ends meet right so the um the telco
provides connectivity um comp companies
make use of that connectivity uh
consumers make use of that connectivity
and attackers as well make use of that
and uh in the telco environment there's
a lot going on and we've seen uh some uh
I can't tell too much but I've seen some
really crazy stuff. Yes. Yes. And when
we say ATPs,
um, actually a sorry, advanced
persistent threats, uh, in Telos, you
can really see those. Yeah, I love it.
Mario, I really want to thank you for,
uh, for the time and for for being here.
Uh this has been a very very informative
and and eye openening and I think that
bringing the CICR context with the CI/CD
uh analogy to the uh security world I
think that's such a cool um cool way of
thinking in general but then being able
to make it practical and methodologizing
it and and uh bringing your expertise
sounds like a really big uh game changer
and and thank you also for sharing your
insights on the human security element.
I appreciate that as well and uh thank
you very much for being here and best of
luck with all your amazing endeavors.
Thank you. Thanks a lot for having me.
Yeah.